oh my god i love blending
[Music]
what's going on in there
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans coming at you
from queen majesty hq in scenic long
island city new york where i'm joined by
erica deal she's the mastermind behind a
pair of hot ones classics including one
of my favorite sauces of all time the
scotch bonnet and ginger sauce we're
here to get the hot sauce making
commandments from the queen herself
we're gonna be doing two sauces today we
have a grilled pineapple and jalapeno
sauce and then the more advanced viewers
out there you know who you are we're
gonna do a sicilian scorpion pepper
sauce but before we get it going how did
you get into the hot sauce game making
it for myself i eat hot sauce on uh
every single thing that i eat so i
couldn't find things that were hot
enough i couldn't find things that were
you know
without sugar or like dyes or weird
ingredients and so i just started
playing around a lot you know i think a
lot of people think that a hot sauce is
maybe hard to make at home and i think
that we'll dispel a lot of that today
that's right but can you talk to me
about some of the mistakes that people
make if they're trying to make their own
hot sauce i would say some of the
hurdles that i've run into yeah putting
too much vinegar in i'm not a big fan of
watery sauces i like sauces with a
little body in there maybe like too
salty i would you know
you don't need as much salt as you might
think you need you know what we've got
our ingredients out i think it's about
time that we make some sauces let's get
to chopping and mixing
[Music]
and first things first we're making a
grilled pineapple and jalapeno sauce can
you break down the ingredients for us
erica how are we starting so we got
fresh pineapple jalapenos garlic lemon
juice salt pepper vinegar olive oil it's
pretty simple sauce to make and it's
designed to be served fresh make a
dinner eat the whole thing let's start
with the pineapple for the first
ingredient
what's the advantage of using pineapple
um it adds a nice acid punch as well as
some sweetness you don't need a lot to
have the desired effect next step is
putting them on the grill why grill the
pineapples that bring out the sweetness
why are we grilling so we're grilling
yes to bring out the sweetness
tenderizes it it gives it a little
caramelization and it has that extra
grill flavor like a little depth to it i
would also um grill them on both sides
just make sure that both sides are
get that nice color to it so we'll keep
an eye on our pineapple and then we'll
move on to our next step which is which
is um jalapenos let's do some jalapenos
then we're using jalapeno in this sauce
which is on you know the lower end of
the spectrum if we're talking the
scoville scale what's special about the
jalapeno i love it because you can use a
lot of them it's not going to add too
much heat
it's kind of a heat that
everyone can enjoy and it's also very
versatile so if you're just getting into
making your own hot sauce at home it's a
good place to start
[Music]
we are prepped in terms of our
ingredients it is chemistry time we just
have to toss it in the blender i
generally tend to start with the liquid
so it's two cups white vinegar how
important is vinegar to the recipe
that's what's preserving your hot sauce
so it's very important and the type of
vinegar you choose is also very
important because it affects the flavor
two cups
into the blender yep perfect bam so we
need two tablespoons of lemon juice
one perfect two
up next is salt and black pepper
throwing some onions in yep jalapenos
going in yep two cups of grilled
pineapple yeah into the blender very
important garlic six of them
[Music]
all right we're on and then we'll just
start picking it up yep
it's oddly satisfying dude good that's
awesome
god i love blending
wow
i actually see the sort of like queen
majesty trademark in that
and you could just use it like that
right away
here we go testing our grilled pineapple
and jalapeno sauce
you roll up to the potluck with some
homemade hot sauce and you just look
like you know what you're doing but
we're not stopping there we are going to
keep the train rolling in our next sauce
it's a little bit more ambitious yes
it's a lot hotter yes it is a sicilian
scorpion sauce so let's
clear slate
and give it a go
so as a maker what's the difference when
you're working with a mild pepper like a
jalapeno versus a super hot like this
thing right here the scorpion pepper
danger basically you have to be a lot
more protected uh wear gloves we should
have like hazmat suits or something yeah
right right right and then we're calling
this the sicilian scorpion sauce what's
our italian twist what are the
ingredients that we have here today
first up we need three cups of apple
cider vinegar i'm on it
this youtube thing doesn't work out is
there a spot in the kitchen here yes
please here we go i'll help you out we
need two tablespoons of sweet vermouth
then two tablespoons of olive oil
[Music]
two tablespoons of italian parsley one
tablespoon of salt one tablespoon of
pepper one cup of sun-dried tomato which
is this whole guy right there
two cups of red bell
and we're putting it in a blender so
sometimes i don't even bother to like
cut it that well it's gonna get cut up
exactly trust me it'll get cut up one
cup of sweet onion
then i think we have some garlic six
yeah see how fast the learner i am good
so we're putting two scorpion peppers
into our hot sauce if you're at home
maybe try with one see where you're at
but we're going just boom zoom straight
to the moon with this one
holy god i love blending
[Music]
[Music]
just dressing some wings over here
that's a lot that's considerable
it's generous all right erica thank you
for having me thank you so much cheers
cheers
it's pretty good
so here's what i'll say about this it is
good
we made a delicious hot sauce
it is very spicy
lots of elements in there
all working together
it tastes it's got some luxury to it
it's got some wood grain to it you know
what i mean yeah thank you well there
you have it now you know how to make
your hot sauce at home
queen majesty pick up a couple cases
it's worth it you heard it here
for the first beef bees fans this is
shawn evans until next time internet
[Music]
you